عوده المشاهدين الى اعلان سلاح الجو
الاسرائيلي ان خللا طرا على منظومه القبه
الحديديه قبل يومين مما حل دون اعتراض
صواريخ اطلقتها المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
غزه على سبيروت فما هي تلك المنظومه التي
كثيرا ما تباهت بها اسرائيل
القبه الحديديه هي نظام دفاعي جوي
بالصواريخ ذو قواعد متحركه
طورته شركه رافائيل الاسرائيليه لانظمه
الدفاع المتقدمه بالتعاون مع الجيش
الامريكي وقد بدا انشاء المنظومه عام 2007
لاعتراض الصواريخ قصيره المدى والقذائف
المدفعيه بعد خسائر اسرائيل خلال حربها
على لبنان عام 2006 دخلت القبه الحديديه
العمله عام 2011 متكونه من جهاز رادار
ونظام تعقب وبطاريه مؤلفه من 20 صاروخا
اعتراضيا تسمى
وتبلغ تكلفه كل صاروخ اعتراض تطلقه حول 50
الف دولار وهو ما اثر انتقادات لتكلفتها
الباهظه
كما تعلقت الانتقادات وايضا بالفاعليه
والنجاعه حيث وجد علماء من شركه رافائيل
المصنعه للمنظومه ان نسبه النجاح الحقيقيه
للاعتراض تبلغ حوالي 5% مقابل نسبه
84% التي يروج لها الجيش الاسرائي
الشكوك حول نجاعه القبه الحديديه في صد
الهجمات شكوك قديمه
ازواجها هذا النظام واخفاقات في السنوات
الماضيه ففي ايار ما يعام 2021 الحقت
المقاومات الفلسطينيه خسائر كبيره
باسرائيل اعتمادا على اطلاق عشرات
الصواريخ والقذائف دفعه واحده وبمضايات
وحمولات متنوعه اربكت المنظومه
الاسرائيليه قبل ذلك فشلت القبه الحديديه
الاسرائيليه في اعتراض صاروخين قديمين من
سوريا سقطا بالقرب من مفاعل ديمونه النووي
وفي اواسط نوفمبر من عام 2019 لم ينجح
النظام الدفاعي الاسرائيلي في اعتراض سوى
نحو 20 صاروخا من اصل 50 صاروخا اطلقتها
المقاومه الفلسطينيه من غزه وكان الوضع
اسوا ثين نوفمبر من عام 2018 عندما لم
تسقط القبه الحديديه الا نحو 100 صاروخ من
اصل 460 صاروخا اطلقتها المقاومه على
اسرائيل